[Music]
let's do okay this is a quick one it's a
quick one
um this is an old old old video maybe
some of you seen it maybe some of you
have it but this is a
this is a video to help kids
um not get abducted by strangers that's
a big problem i mean
it's a big problem i'm trying to i'm
trying to date this right now
mm-hmm
uh
i don't know i'm not really sure what
dates
it's it's
at least 15 years old let's say i'm just
looking at it because i'm trying well
you're
setting it up and i'm like all right i'm
just trying to figure it out okay so you
ready yeah i'm trying to prepare myself
okay let's see we'll figure it out all
right this is an actual this is an
actual video by the way this isn't like
this isn't a goof or anything all right
here we go
you've already been told about strangers
dressing up in uniforms but there are
other traps you need to know about okay
this is very old hi i lost my little dog
can you help me find him
no
i'm sorry why not i got to go ride bikes
with my friends you want a dog nope but
the dog ran away thanks nope
okay let's see if you say no to the next
one okay be suspicious of an adult
asking for help
hi i'm just playing with my daughter's
video game but the batteries seem to be
dead i have some in my car why don't you
come over and help me put them yes yes
i'm on my way
me first
we're kids we're pushing each other out
of the way about batteries right
what batteries [ __ ] throw that thing
in the garbage [ __ ] first of all she
got tetris and she got titties i'm all
in are you all in is there chicks like
this going around just going hey little
boy is this still happening because i'm
gonna tell you i don't remember this as
a kid when i was almost molested on a
cruise ship it was an old indian man it
was not a a lady like this yeah there
was no ch there was no [ __ ] girls
that age was trying to [ __ ] a teenage me
or preteen me somebody in the chat says
abduct me mommy
seriously
i'm going with you
wherever she went was preferred to where
i grew up anyway
mike's like at least i'm getting
molested i want her to be hot are you
kidding me or her
all putting the putting all of those in
the plus category of things oh [ __ ]
hell
hi i'm just playing with my daughter's
video game but the batteries seem to be
dead i have some in my car why don't you
come over and help me put them in
i'll help you put whatever you want in
details wherever you want them put
[Laughter]
sorry
oh boy
oh [ __ ] everyone in the chat's like okay
short yep i'm on my way [ __ ] there's no
can i be the battery
gee this is
guys can i can i be the battery can i be
the batteries please
[Laughter]
all right come on mike
you're trying to save kids here i'm
sorry you're right let's save some
children thank you
stay away from people in cars or fans
hey kid how you doing
come on it's immediate pedophile right
right away it's not even a doubt
this was immediate
[Laughter]
clearly an actor but why did ethan
roth's dad do this commercial
hey he needed the money
how you doing
um
you know we're making a movie over there
you want to go see it
only professionally some porno
um
it's a movie
um
you know we're making a movie over there
you want to go see it
only professional agencies hire kids for
tv work and then they molest them oh
well do you get the gut you get the gig
definitely and then they molest them
that's fair
a young dan schneider firing for his tv
shows this guy is like he looks like a
young version of remember the coach from
major league
oh okay yeah yeah yeah
hi i don't know
hey kid let's go to the arcade and play
some video games
this is hilarious
hey kids guys
wait what what was the last part the
video game oh yeah i love video games
yeah i can't i'm helping this [ __ ] put
batteries in her [ __ ] game boy yeah
sorry man sorry bro so annoying yeah
she's oh my god she keeps putting it
backwards yeah and then she keeps
putting my penis in her mouth and i'm
like ew all right gross
hey kid let's go to the arcade and play
some video games what do you say
ignore him and walk away little boy i'll
give you ten dollars if you'll take my
bags of the car for me
ten bucks
ten bucks
all right lady but i'm not giving you
the whole boyfriend experience no ten
bucks
you know what i mean like you want to
get [ __ ] and get these groceries
carried now i'm thinking of little
gigolo merch little chickaletta cost you
something you lady i mean
[ __ ] nine-year-old merch is sitting
up by the [ __ ] swing smoking i light
a cigarette i'm like
so look what are we talking about here
and then i'm just i'm so jaded and ready
that they're like oh never mind i'm
gonna go find it come straight come
straight at me come on i'm looking for a
kid that has like life in his eyes i'm
sorry i made a mistake that's not a
mistake you're nine but your soul is 60.
i just can't
look i could do a happy or like you know
something like that for i don't know 20.
and you also talk like you do now too
which would be even better putting a
cigarette out immediately lighting
another cigarette like this kid is
[ __ ] nuts
it's okay to say no even to an adult
safety is more important than good
manners hey kid
i'll teach you how to hit this ball
right over the fence
that's a weird
flex hey kid it's a weird flex but okay
right that's
hey kid
come on it'll be fun well i'll teach you
how to throw the sickest spirals
wait what what i'm going to show you to
crush sports crush person play sports
hey kid you like you like you like
brendan's shop
you want to meet him
no thank you
trust your own feelings i know i'd
rather get
how they get by an adult
in a ball field
trust your own feelings
[Applause]
oh boy this is the emergency trap
your mom's been hurt she's in the
hospital she sent me to come and get you
i hate that [ __ ] [ __ ] her
[Laughter]
that would be really [ __ ] that [ __ ]
good i'm glad she's hurt
good i'm go what you [ __ ] fall off
new daddy's dick
[ __ ] cards this kid's like i don't have
a mom nice try [ __ ]
she's dead she pulls out a switchblade
[ __ ] give me your purse
give me a purse you [ __ ] [ __ ]
never try to pull up on a kid they might
rob you it turns into a totally
different bs
careful for violent children don't
kidnap kids in florida they might have a
gun on them
mom's been hurt she's in the hospital
she sent me to come and get you what's
the secret code word the n-word
you have to say the word she's like say
the word
do i have to say the word you want this
commercial
why aren't you taking this seriously
mike
telling his parent if your little girl
wants this commercial i need
the most emphatic n-word i've ever heard
in my life
and they're in their pep talk
it's the same way when these kids get in
hollywood she's going to do what he says
all right if he tells you he tells you
to say a word that mommy and daddy
usually don't like just say the word say
the word
mike i don't think this is helping
sorry
your mom's been hurt she's in the
hospital she sent me to come and get you
who do you think put her there you
stupid [ __ ]
click and now give me the car
civic this sucks
what a terrible kid
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh
what's the secret code word
i don't know the code word you don't
need what if her mom was in a coma and
didn't give the code word though that's
what i'm thinking
the kid just runs and knocks on a
neighbor's door and then the neighbor
kidnapped
him
i need to get near the car to talk to
someone inside
first off you can run as fast as you
want she has a car
you know you look like you could use a
friend say no to what you think say no
to friendship
live a lonely life
the message of this video kids when
people are being nice to you run away
trust nobody run away
be a crazy person
[Laughter]
this is just paranoia seriously this is
paranoia videos
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] just run away every time
honey that was your teacher do you not
allowed to do that he didn't know the
secret phrase he's your teachers he's
supposed to he figured he was exempt
from
the secret phrase
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
um they know to what you think is wrong
pizza delivery
that would have got me i'm a fat kid i
would but pizza
what kind of pizza from what place from
where it doesn't matter open the door
anyway
it doesn't matter it's pizza
come on open the door
nothing is more important than your
safety uh crazy bread is more important
than my safety he better have the pizza
too because there's nothing worse than a
personal child
also and also reneged on the pizza right
it's tucker carlson
that's all i see now in this guy yeah
look at it look at the tucker face
seriously
hey kid do you not do you not like the
elite taking your health care and this
is why the elites are outsourcing your
pizza jobs to other pedophiles
pedophiles who aren't from this country
undercover tucker that's hard to work on
a tucker now
pedophiles who aren't from this country
we used to have homegrown pedophiles in
this we have well yeah whereas we have
pedophiles right here in america right
now
willing to deliver our pizzas why are we
going to give them a fair wage
with me now is lieutenant colonel
ron parker some dude and then two
minutes ten minutes later and join me
after the break i'll be joined by nancy
grace like why
nancy grace coming up yeah i don't want
her here either we have a theory and i
have this theory that [ __ ] tucker
crossing gets he has his list and fox
news has their list in every episode
he's allowed to get one from each
so every episode he gets in the guy that
he like really takes seriously it's
coming up next nancy grace and who are
these people tucker i mean who are they
who are these people tucker and he's
like
nancy
he does the paper stuff click click
thank you nancy
that's just the weirdest thing watching
tucker carlson it's like they're [ __ ]
with them all right you can have your
lieutenant colonel who former c.i.a guy
on the show uh and then after that
you're having um judge napolitano god i
have to
and you're like what i'm telling you
there's a bunch of wackadoos over there
democrats
thank you judge we'll be back
sorry come on open the door
it's more important there it is right
there that's the tucker face right there
than your safety
[Applause]
hi
you're sure a cute kid
you know what's sad about this guy
the only thing he could ever be since he
was a kid was a pedophile like that's
his job like that's what his high school
guidance
council like i don't know you're
probably not going to be thrilled about
it but yeah you're probably just
pedophile would i that's what i would do
that's what i in your line of work i
would get into that line of work if i
were you
you know
i'm a professional photographer oh no
ah
no
no
i love how on the nose this is like
these kids are gonna have these amazing
uh uh
just
like you're honestly let's be fair
if your kids
were kidnapped by guys that look like
this they deserve to be
like there's no it needed to be
well it's
natural
you know whatever natural selection um
you even as a kid you should go
oh no yeah you totally look like a
pedophile
that's what's called the hero trap by
the way the hero trap hi
you're sure a cute kid
you know i'm a professional photographer
[ __ ] off loser i'm sure put these
batteries in this game boy
this is it this is it [ __ ] the hero
trap the guy pulls up to a bunch of high
school kids and goes hey what's going on
you want to serve your country and get
free health care
that's the hero trap and that's what
that's and that's worse
that's worse than molesting you at least
molesting a kid is over at some point
the most insidious one is the hero trap
hey i tell you what you'll probably get
stationed in okinawa what do you say
nice build your credit go to school for
free and then it's just immediately to
iraq
you want to buy a dodge charge that's
gonna depreciate in value while you're
in iraq
oh man that's come on guys
we love we love our armed service people
rock flag and eagle gun
come on hop in the car i'll take your
picture if someone wants to take your
picture say no and unless it's me
tell your parents if you tell anybody
about our little secret why is rikishi
out here
no what this is the sumo from the street
fighter movie really does look like
every fat guy character ever he looks
like rikishi he does look like uh piston
honda e honda or ihon honda piston hot
is the boxer from punch up also looks
like him okay a little bit fair is he
wearing a wig
i don't know tell him also looks like
like a like a samoan shack
you know some old jack
don't tell your parents i have to kill
them too
buddy
about our little secret
i'll kill your dog oh jesus that
escalated wow why just the dog i feel
like that's not enough
to really put it on the line and the
kid's there with a bloody shirt too late
like you were your dog at this point you
were a child now you're threatening him
to stay silent i say you go for the
gusto and you say hey i'm gonna kill
your parents and you and everyone your
sister and everybody and your entire
family well jesus now now i don't want
to do it you're just like he stopped it
dog
kill your dog and it's like yeah i know
but
you know get a new dog
should never be asked to keep special
secrets from their parents now you know
the 11 most common unless it's the fact
that you're trans and want to go on
hormone and puberty blockers keep that
[ __ ] to yourself if you want to get an
abortion that's different but other
people we met people other than weird
creepy counselors at your school who
they're allowed to talk to you without
your parents permission and if you want
to cut your penis off you're right if
you want to let a strange doctor stick
his hand up your [ __ ] and rip out a
baby that's fine
we met other secrets with other adults
that aren't medically trained yeah
parents now you know the 11 most common
kidnapped traps to avoid and how to be
straight did you write them down
i didn't know we were going to be tested
hey could someone write those down for
me yeah so now it's now i'm going to get
molested seriously i don't want to get
molested i'm still thinking a game boy
girl
be smart the time to start is now be
cautious and observant and report
anything suspicious
[Music]
this music is amazing there's a review
there's a review you ready for the
review okay
the eleven traps to avoid are helping
thriving
being famous
having fun
getting a job
being a playmate
what emergency
affection
authority
hero
and threats all the things that will
make you successful youtuber today this
is remember when they would make these
things back then
and they're so poorly done by the end
that you've learned nothing no it's even
the way they've just it's so this is so
hideous and ugly and it provides no
information so i wasn't paying attention
is this i wasn't paying attention what
games would you have for that game boy
this feels like
this almost feels like a parody
it's no i know but it just feels like
one with the with the with the amount of
like almost not serious information and
everything that was presented you're
like what was the point of this if this
was on tim and eric late at night i
wouldn't even
i would be giggling at it you're right